let's go to uh the governor of yuma
arizona or the mayor i should say tug
nichols i apologize there uh i know the
governor has gone ahead and said look
the president won't you know build a
wall
i will and he's using a lot of shipping
containers to do that i know that is
something you endorse where does this
stand and what are you going to do
well they've identified six gaps that
they're going to first target and so i
understand that they're on the third gap
and that's within a week so they've been
very effective on getting uh the
containers in place and getting them
secured and then moving on to the next
gap so when you hear mayor the
administration argue that walls don't
work um but we do know this much that
where there are walls particularly along
south of san diego anymore um
they they certainly do work
that's absolutely true and we have
history of that we don't have to even
look in the recent history we can go
back to 2006 when
president bush sent the national guard
to build a wall we had a 98 drop in
crossings that one year alone
it's irrefutable it doesn't solve
immigration but it does make the country
more secure
so this latest
revelation now that 2 million migrants
expected to be apprehended at the border
that does not include as you've often
reminded me mayor those who got away but
what do you suspect
well i think we're looking at you know
seven to 800 a day right now so you know
if the governor can secure some of these
gaps then it helps keep that number at
least under control
um it is a short-term solution but at
the end end of the day uh we need to try
to find a way to push back on on that 2
million number and keep that
well get that down
is there a timeline sir as to when you
hope to complete or the governor hopes
to complete these shipping container
walls
well the current plan is just six gaps
there's over 50 gaps in the wall in
human sector so i don't know if the
whole plan is to try to hit all of those
gaps but these are the most active gaps
and the most
vulnerable for our cities in our
community when these drugs and the bad
actors come through so that's why these
were prioritized really as a reflection
to protect the communities mayor thank
you very much mayor doug nichols of yuma
arizona hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now